all right let's do it cooking a roundup
of everything else we saw first all
TrackMania turbo no one expected that Oh
hands up if you like trackmania yeah
like it looked fun anything they said
they had a VR demo yes good thing it
actually gets sick on V or I feel like
that might be the quickest way to get
sick on view I just need to vomit yeah
yeah Oh God just thinking of it now
makes me think oh my oh there was a game
called toy box turbos which very similar
premise and they did it in via but they
did it you know the camera pulled way
back and kind of following along and
that didn't kind of word can I didn't
that was gonna going from third person
to first person and there you have it
around so fast so this really looks like
trackmania nations which was a cobble
live it's about maybe four years old
going there before all that maybe a
planet nonsense so we don't know if
they're actually going to keep with
mania planet that was when they beliefs
trackmania and they had like you did you
got like are you get to buy stadium and
you to buy all your different like areas
and this one they say there's going to
be four environments off the track 200
tracks they also have their sort of
procedurally generated track thing as
well variety of cars as well it's kind
of like f1 v8 looking things there and
some other type of dirt cars yeah and
also a virtual reality mmm they go and a
bitchin hat yeah sweet yep truck manis
back in a big way and for a second air
it also looked like we had some sort of
like a [ __ ] what was that like I can
on it with everything George Sanders
it's dark centers and it's a cat riding
a fire-breathing unicorn the double
rainbow in the background do I go of
course it's Charles few trials fusions
expansion back now guys like his rod so
this is like the blood dragon for trials
right yeah add this an expansion pack
were you what is your cat riding a
unicorn I mean if everything you're also
funny is so fimo edgy what welcome to
the future then lay knows anything just
like just let this speak for itself ya
know triple rainbow there's a whole
bunch of knots is gonna this is awesome
level max which is the expansion coming
soon for fats
transfusion add there's new add-on game
is an allure I know to a widget to 2050
yeah so what was last 120 70 70 yeah so
they're going so mature again on future
again you decided with a moon I did play
this is that I can't get into specifics
until tomorrow but we know that it
exists now and so yeah the moon and it's
a city builder and there's a hole I mean
if you've played the Animus series where
you sort of know what you're getting
into and so you know a trade game you
know a game where you build city and
you're trading to make your citizens
more and more happy and to expand and
stuff like that but with the moon yeah
and I guess to be more on that on
gamespot tomorrow Kevin yeah totally
sweet and moving swiftly on who knew
they had some dancing happening JC just
turned up that was like do you remember
when I sure appeared the microsoft press
conference can I forget there he is
there it is do it I'm shaking yeah
whatever you're no Prince Jason and this
is coming in on a bunch of platforms
they're also bringing it just dance
unlimited on ps4 xbox one and Wii U I
think they also have fun they also said
you can play with your phone now great
when she said that last year yeah don't
even need a console well the best is to
play it to dance with my phone yeah when
people look at me while I'm dancing
looking at my phone Oh plaintiff all our
beam while they're dancing up I mean I
mean nothing like this not much you can
say about just dance yeah yeah this is
the game of what you dance now let's
stretch let's keep going let's keep on
five minutes I'm just Oh hundred fifty
of the greatest just dance hits new
songs all of her head seen Gangnam style
alright recognize yeah oh good but I
think the best presentation I know we
like to Jason dilute the wrong room how
about an actual Viking coming out on
stage Oh game that guy for honor that
looks awesome beard guy is the best guy
that ever guide in the history know
you're a fan of a beard guy yeah the
beard guy was the best guy and he is the
Dark Lord yes on Twitter I swear the
underscore Dark Lord Lord with an e I'd
like to point out so he's the underscore
dark lordy so you should follow this
dude because he's frightening
great kimber that beard guy evangelist
what did you think of for honor I want
that combat in Assassin's Creed why
can't we have that kind of like Shiva it
looks like chivalry but does it have
MOBA elements cuz it looked like there
was stuff going on in the background
like maybe this is yeah like I was kind
of thinking do I rira furring to those
mobile like titanfall does that we don't
say that's a MOBA oh yeah well I mean I
know it's hard to tell hmm I thought
maybe there were creeps and there were
like you know like territory to control
i guess you move further towards the
yeah the enemy camp but i don't know i
could be just making the [ __ ] up so i go
looks fun that's kind of what i'm doing
actually i'm at the last game to talk
about so park the fractured bought hole
Oh what you what naming behold they
really want a 9.5 on games I don't have
the heart to tell them we don't even
have 9.5 anymore but I'll go with it
come with it at tray and mass back on
stage doing it again this time obsidian
not involved ubisoft san francisco
apparently ah not really a surprise yeah
i'm not surprised either but why an
obsidian isn't is it is it is a good
developer but they do other things hmm i
think better than what they did with
with South Park's okay yeah i loved
stick of truth but i thought it was a
little too like formula or simple it was
a little too formulaic it was a simple
Rosie vibrant and hilarious and awesome
and there was so much more to do with it
um I like the game but I think that
maybe that maybe this is an opportunity
for Ubisoft enough to really push the
boundaries there well I also think
obsidian moves to new things lately they
don't really stick with something well
that's all that Ubisoft had to show for
us we're gonna take a quick little break
and we will be back right here on the
game spot I guess war room stage Sony's
kicking off in just a little bit of
times we're gonna start our pre-show for
that so stay tuned and we'll be back
girl would it
you